retour en france dans notre page
vacances l'été des îles nous nous
rendons à bréhat au large de paimpol un
petit endroit merveilleux où sont
installés de nombreux artistes notamment
des écrivains un petit coin de paradis
qui voit chaque jour pendant la saison
estivale des centaines de touristes
défilent et le soir lille retrouve son
calme mais les familles qui vivent
depuis longtemps regrettent leur bréhat
d'antan nathalie cause de nos villes
l'île de bréhat au large de paimpol un
paradis pris d'assaut chaque jour par
5000 touristes
bré à trois kilomètres de long appelé
depuis longtemps l'île aux fleurs est
surnommé aujourd'hui l'île des parisiens
les bateaux transportant dix minutes ces
vacanciers de passage des gens vu d'ici
un peu trop pressés et ils ont fait le
tour de bras ils sont contents et ils ne
regardent pas il y en a beaucoup qui
regarde pas qui ciblent il en courant et
il ya une partie qui s'intéresse plus
bertrand et 100% il y un les touristes
il les connaît bien ne pas qu à
septembre il leur fait faire le tour de
l'île dans son tracteur taxi car ici pas
de voiture et pas de route des touristes
attirés aussi par un climat tempéré et
un paysage encore épargnée on a pas mal
d'amis chez nous qui est qu'ils en
parlaient que c'était vraiment efficace
demandez nature ça m'a tenu à caractère
typique en règle générale jean tigana
bréhat reste beaucoup lille on voit que
c'est quand même bien propre bien
entretenu il ya un respect des délais
puis des habitants où on se pince mais
les bréhat temps sont plus remontés
contre ces envahisseurs quotidien 20h
dernier bateau pour le continent il se
vide
reste les touristes résidents avec leur
maison leur jardin ils font vivre bréhat
ces commerçants c'est trois agriculteurs
au total 470 habitants depuis le bref on
de le dire ce fut notre brillant avec la
mentalité qu'il les espions ont les
nouveaux je dis bien les nouveaux
touristes qui vont acheter les maisons à
prix de combien très très cher que nos
veines ne peuvent pas fait maison
ici la moindre maison se négocie
maintenant un million de francs dont le
village la mairie vient d'aménager des
hlm pour que les jeunes bray atteint
puisse rester sur l'île